[Music]
get
the idea of something Bing us together
you know that love is enough when
IES about
thata to is one it's collectively
unconsciously
[Music]
t
I lost my head in San Francisco waiting
for the to roll out but I found in R CL
was sming down feel the love I feel the
love come on come on let's start let it
out of your soul
oh
[Music]
I get in love with love and idea of
something binding us together you know
that love is strong enough and I speak
time tell tales about that systematic Dr
that heart that beats this one is
collectively our conscious
feel the love I feel the love come on
come on
let let it pour out of your
soul you feel the love I feel the love
come on come on
let's your soul
[Music]
n
I
[Applause]